Ariana Grande's got hubby Dalton Gomez's
full support I feel love every day while
Ari's busy filming away during
production of Wicked the film adaptation
of the Broadway musical a source sells
E.T how her booze showing up for her
hell yeah do you know what I mean quote
Ariana has been so focused but Dalton
has been there with her in supporting
her behind the scenes he is happy for
her and they are very in love
what I'm grateful as for how Ari's
feeling as she takes on the role of
Glinda
et's Insider says it's her dream and
she's throwing herself fully into it and
Dalton is supportive it's a very
exciting thing for us yeah Ariana's
loving the wicked life check out her
sneak peeks from the set including this
pick with Cynthia arrivo who's starring
as Elphaba we're already excited that
Ariana and I consistently texting and
talking about what we want and just last
week fans caught a first Glimpse at the
stars in full costume
I am so excited for this
um it's weird because it's exhausting
but I am not tired like I would do it
again right now every single thing I I
don't want to stop I don't want to do
the weekends I don't want to go home I
don't want to leave ever so Cynthia and
I are this is the phrase we keep saying
husks we are shells of people
and I'm savoring every single second
humanly possible but both of us are
working really really hard and we're
trying to bring you something that you
might not expect it is not going to vary
too far away hopefully from the stage
but I think you'll get more from it now
I think you'll get more of the story of
the two of these wonderful characters
who have lots of life to give yeah and
the star study cast only gets bigger
oh Wicked last December it was announced
Michelle Yos joined in on the fun I know
you're about to go to London to shoot
wicked wicked what can we expect oh my
God Ariana and Cynthia yeah they okay
first to start off
um John Chu I love John Chu we did crazy
rejections to the together and he called
me and he says can I meet with you
please please don't like of course John
you know he's the sweetest so then he
said well I would love if you would come
and join us in in London and I was like
Johnny what are you doing so wicked and
then he then I said okay he's going to
send me the script please you know
consider it then he goes off and two
days later I'm I get a message from him
and he has recorded a message from
Ariana and Cynthia and him saying hi
Michelle it's imperative
imperative absolutely what was it
imperative that you join us now it was
so sweet but I don't sing
fans can expect Wicked coming out in two
parts November 2024 and December 2025.
[Music]
thank you